un risque de 175 grammes tout droit venu
des états unis
il est très proche de votre frisbee mais
ne vous y trompez pas celui ci est dédié
à la compétition
au même titre que le coc tennis 1 vous
pouvez avoir un coup droit en revers
donc le coup droit ici et le revers dans
l'autre sens on a aussi ce qu'on appelle
le lobe ou l'aube side qu'on passe au
dessus donc on a différents on n'a pas
de restriction au niveau du lancer
on peut lancer vraiment n'importe
comment la par l'important c'est que le
coéquipier rattrape le frisbee sens qui
tombe par terre ou sans qu'il soit
réceptionnée par un adversaire
le but du jeu faire parvenir le disque
dans l'en but adverse autant de passes
que l'on veut mais pas le droit de
marcher avec le disque en salle
la partie se joue en 25 minutes outre et
ce point en auto arbitrage une trentaine
de pratiquants en france à la fin des
années 80 environ 5000 maintenant le
sport se pratique beaucoup en scolaire
c'est là que quand on a attrapé le virus
l'ultime être vrai sport d'équipé le
collectif c'est super important dans ce
temps là dans une petite équipe on joue
à dix et encore les équipes qui joua
avec encore moins de joueurs en gymnase
et là bas ça fait ça fait trois ans
qu'on a monté un peu ce petit collectif
on est cinq ou six à rester tous les ans
dans l'équipe
d'après ya des joueurs qui gravite un
peu autour qui arrive qui partent et
c'est ce même collectif au collectif de
se renouveler aussi
voilà c'est important pour l'équipe
d'avoir ce noyau ce noyau la base de
lier à orléans ils sont deux piliers à
avoir connu le plus haut niveau national
et international
la france est classée huitième nation
mondiale troisième des championnats
d'europe en 2015 au danemark
benjamin en était un mordu lui aussi est
le petit mail c'est le summum du sport
collectif puisque c'est un verre art
sport on ne peut pas marquer tout seul
je veux qu'on peut pas se démarquer
on ne peut pas courir avec le disque au
foot et des actions individuelles dans
plein de sports et des actions
individuelles altimate n'existe pas on
est obligé de jouer en équipe quoi de
parler règle la région centre val de
loire à sally beauty m depuis deux ans
maintenant huit clubs au total dont deux
au plus haut niveau
orléans et blois cela n'est valable que
d'octobre à mars
aux beaux jours on sort en france on
joue à l'intérieur l'hiver parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup d'infrastructures de
stade couvert quand il pleut quand il
neige à l'achat on a mis en place ce jeu
à l'intérieur dont beaucoup de pays
d'europe ça se fait à l'international ça
se fait relativement peu la discipline
reine c'est l'extérieur qui joue sur un
terrain de rugby à peine réduit en
largeur et à 7 contre 7 ultimate en
salle sur erdre ou sur sable hommes
dames ou mixtes bientôt sport olympique
pourquoi placer rater pour tous que 2001
peut-être paris 2024
non